[Musica]
ti è mai capitato di chiedervi
cosa ci faccio qui questo non è il mio
posto
almeno una volta nella vita e nel mio
caso Almeno una volta al giorno
sentiamo di essere in adatti
alieni atterrati su un pianeta che non è
propriamente il nostro
e mi è sempre piaciuto sentirmi adatto
dico davvero non che dovesse esserlo ad
ogni costo Ma quel mix di noia e
monotonia non mi ha mai realmente
soddisfatto Eppure ci sono tanti
tantissimi come me che vorrebbero
soltanto confondersi nella folla e
abbracciare La mediocrità nella speranza
di vivere senza ansia e senza paure
Ovviamente ognuno compie le proprie
scelte certo medico di no perché
privarsi della propria diversità sarebbe
come togliere quel neo a Marilyn Monroe
Mick Jagger era Rolling Stones
ho il monociglio a Frida Kahlo ognuno di
noi assumoti è diverso certo diversità
su cui dobbiamo puntare follemente fino
ad ubriacarcene Ecco prendete con le
pinze ciò che sto per dirvi credo che i
piani B siano deleteri Beh ovviamente
viviamo in una società che non ci
permette di non averne ma sono soltanto
una distrazione
un esempio lampante può essere ogni
giorno durante le ore di matematica
viaggio che pensieri fissando il voto o
meglio sono più specifico fisso uno
spiraglio che sta tra la porta e l'uscio
bene in quello spiraglio io vedo il mio
futuro
le cose che ci annoiano ci portano
inevitabilmente a pensare a quello che
in realtà ci appassiona
quello che possiamo fare
è fare ogni scelta compiere ogni passo
per diventare la versione migliore di
noi stessi
io non posso che ringraziare ogni ora di
matematica In che non ho capito nulla
della lezione
perché è lì che la mia mente ha
viaggiato e mi ha permesso di capire
quello che in realtà voglio essere
seppure ancora sono un po' indeciso
perché annoiarsi In un mondo che ci
offre costantemente le distrazioni nuove
per i social per i telefoni e un lusso È
incredibile non dobbiamo mai
dimenticarlo
dalla noia nasce la creatività perché
ogni piano b c d e f o z non è altro che
una versione del nostro futuro così ci
piace ci soddisfa ma mai pienamente
perché ogni cosa che facciamo deve
essere dedita al nostro piano a alla
nostra completa realizzazione
quante volte invece un vostro familiare
Vi avrà detto Beh con questo lavoro non
avrei mai problemi nella vita per carità
sicuramente i vostri zii e le cene di
natale avranno ragione
Ma io in quanto ragazzi 17 anni non
potrei mai fare qualcosa che non amo per
tutta la vita sarebbe una bugia bella e
buona che poi le bugie sono un grande
fan delle Bugie a fin di bene ma
ovviamente raccontata agli altri non a
se stessi perché i conti si fanno con la
propria coscienza alla fine e non con
quella degli altri l'unico modo che
abbiamo per diventare veramente
protagonisti della nostra vita è quello
di conoscersi a fondo
trovare ciò che si ama e farlo a
qualsiasi costo guardare la propria vita
dall'alto senza avere paura di capire
che magari stiamo un po' sbagliando ma
nessun disegno viene perfetto senza
delle prove
seppur tutto ciò possa essere Bizzarro e
controcorrente perché tanto nessuno vi
darà una pacca sulla spalla all'infuori
di vostra madre
e dato che ormai stiamo parlando era un
po' metto comodo e penso di potervi
raccontare qualcosa che mi riguarda
ho iniziato a studiare musica all'età di
8 anni giocavo già a calcio ma con
scarsi risultati Cioè oddio Io pensavo
di essere il nuovo Maradona ma forse
perché 8 anni ero già il doppio rispetto
agli altri bambini però crescendo ho
capito che non era affatto quella la mia
strada il motivo per il quale ho
iniziato a studiare musica e tanto
semplice quanto buffo
ricordo di ogni festa di famiglia dove
quel bambino alto un metro e poco più
chiedeva di cantare una canzone sempre
la stessa canzone una canzone che ho
ascoltato la prima volta in un CD un po'
rigato di mia madre in macchina di mia
madre una canzone che è arrivata
undicesima al Festival di Sanremo del 96
Ma che invece una canzone che Per me ha
significato l'inizio della cosa più
bella della mia vita una canzone che
nessuno di voi Probabilmente conosce o
pochi di voi e che nemmeno io conoscerei
se non fosse la canzone preferita di mio
padre L'elefante e la farfalla di
Michele Zarrillo
Ma questa è un'altra storia
così dopo tutte queste esibizioni
occasionali decisi di chiedere
finalmente i miei se potessi frequentare
una scuola di musica continuando però
parallelamente a giocare a calcio
Così mentre i miei amici passavano tutte
il loro pomeriggio con una palla tra i
piedi io passavo le mie ore con una
chitarra e qualche spartito tra le mani
che poi pensandoci a posteriori tutto
ciò non è altro che un esempio lampante
di quello che il disagio sociale che ci
provoca il giudizio degli altri perché
pensate bene questa situazione i miei
amici mi chiedevano insistentemente di
andare a giocare con loro a calcio che
Poi per carità a me piace tantissimo
giocare ma io invece di dire che quel
pomeriggio preferivo suonare
inventavo qualche stupida scusa perché
non è effettivamente quello che loro
dicevano ma ciò che mi aspettavo che
loro avrebbero potuto dire pensare
queste immagini mi terrorizzava mi
sentivo come Benjamin Button un fenomeno
da baraccone gravemente incompreso
col tempo però ho capito che l'unico
nemico che mi separasse davanti ero
proprio io e la mia stupida paranoia
perché in realtà i miei amici così come
la mia famiglia i miei genitori e le mie
sorelle mi hanno sempre supportato Anzi
oggi voglio cogliere proprio l'occasione
per ringraziarli perché in un mondo dove
pensare con la propria testa e cosa rara
loro mi hanno permesso di scegliere da
solo di riscendere il bene del male
anche sbagliando mi hanno imboccato
verso il percorso più giusto che però
era sempre affine alla mia personalità e
se oggi sono quello che sono seppur
pieno di difetti e soprattutto grazie a
loro
Ovviamente non tutti sono entusiasti
della mia scelta di vivere di musica
l'unità durante una cena di diverso
tempo fa
lo sapete meglio di me le zie sono
quegli esseri mitologici metà
giornaliste metà donne che non aspetta
un altro che Natale per farvi milioni di
domande ma io quell'anno ero
preparatissimo
le tre risposte erano No zia non ho la
fidanzata Si sto mangiando e a scuola
tutto bene
quell'anno però c'erano una novità la
domanda e la fidanzatina era stata
sostituita da una domanda tanto più
complicata che cosa vuoi fare da grande
Beh dopo questa domanda mi sentivo come
quando la Netflix hanno tolto poi metto
il mother Ero spaventato e sorpreso
però
[Musica]
Forse perché in realtà non mi ero mai
posto veramente questa domanda con il
senno di poi e forse perché l'unica
costante della mia vita sarebbe sempre
stata la musica così tutto fiero risposi
Beh io voglio continuare con la musica
la risposta fu No no io intendo che
lavoro vuoi fare
Beh Ammetto che l'idea di prendere la
rincorsa e buttarmi al balcone mi balena
nata in testa per circa due secondi però
preferite evitare di farlo era
arrabbiato tantissimo ma non con mia zia
perché capisco che il contesto storico
in cui abitiamo è completamente diverso
in cui siamo cresciuti ovviamente
se per lei il lavoro è uno stipendio
sicuro un posto fisso o un ufficio
fatiscente Per me il lavoro non è altro
che fare ciò che amiamo
e in quel momento sulla lista delle cose
che odio la società ho aggiunto un nuovo
punto l'incapacità di guardare oltre la
boccia di vetro in cui siamo stati
rinchiusi
come detto era arrabbiato Anzi
arrabbiatissimo con tutti perché davvero
quanto è triste pensare un mondo dove i
sogni sono soltanto un'utopia e come
credere di possedere la luna e
ritrovarsi ma non Sasso deludente
proprio ho pensato un sasso si è
scagliato con tutta la forza possibile
quel vetro lo può rompere come
invito quindi chiunque a sognare in
grande perché nessuno merita di guardare
alla propria vita con sufficienza e una
buona dose di rammarico
rimanendo sempre umili Certo perché
quella è la prima prerogativa Per
riuscire in qualsiasi cosa nella vita
infatti c'è un motto che mi accompagna
da diversi anni da quando è iniziato a
studiare musica in realtà volare in alto
ma con i piedi per terra
e quanti sono invece gli artisti che
hanno rischiato pur di arrivare dove
sono Che si parli di musica di teatro di
pittura di Radio di cinema tutti no
immaginateli tutti i pesci in faccia
tutte le zie che anche loro hanno
chiesto cosa volessero fare da grandi
è un prezzo giusto per la realizzazione
Io penso proprio di sì
e il prezzo giusto per fare qualcosa di
nuovo
che poi anche il concetto di nuovo è
molto labile Quanti di voi
hanno almeno in playlist una canzone che
è uscita più di 10 anni fa anzi azzardi
mo' 20 anni fa
praticamente tutti giusto
vi faccio capire anche il perché
Ho bevuto troppo meglio se mi riportano
da te Ti ho colpita sono tutti
la conoscete Vabbè la conosciamo tutti
Purtroppo però
cosa risponderesti Se invece vi dicessi
Se per caso cadesse il mondo
questa canzone che ho appena cantato
anziché Abbiamo appena cantato e di
Raffaella Carrà ed è del 78 ma intanto
lo sappiamo tutti
in questi ultimi anni vi sarà
sicuramente capitato anche di sentire
qualche tormentone estivo del 2015 2016
o 17 e dire Cavolo quanto ascoltato
questa canzone quasi come se aveste la
nausea Come si come se vi fosse preso un
overdose da musica spazzatura Perché
Perché ormai ci si basa più sulla
quantità che sulla qualità della musica
Fate attenzione a ciò che sto per dirvi
sicuramente la qualità dei tormentoni
estivi sarà ottima perché ci sono dietro
delle produzioni devastanti ma degli
ultimi brani quanti resteranno davvero
nel tempo se hanno già il difetto di
stancare dopo una sola estate
che poi quante volte in discoteca avete
ballato canzoni di altre epoche per dire
l'altro giorno mi è capitato di andare
in discoteca e ascoltare una canzone di
Alan Sorrenti Figli delle stelle che poi
magari detta così non capita nemmeno che
canzone sia ma se sentite appunto il
riff che sta all'inizio della canzone La
conoscerete tutti
[Musica]
E allora perché le canzoni vecchie come
le chiamiamo noi ci piacciono
perché non esiste Né musica Vecchia né
musica nuova Esiste la buona e la
cattiva musica
Grazie
[Applauso]
è proprio su questo filone Sono mossi
molto artisti anche di canzoni che vanno
adesso virali su Tik Tok Quante canzoni
adesso riprendono i ritmi giri e
progressioni di pezzi di anche 70 anni
fa come per esempio questo che io
apprezzo molto in realtà
[Musica]
comunque Ragazzi grazie
e poi ci sono artisti e band che non
smetteranno mai di essere icone
perché non perché in realtà sia
difficile scrivere la buona musica vi
faccio un esempio un certo Paul
McCartney per dirne uno piccolino
ha scritto uno dei pezzi più belli che i
Beatles lo abbiano mai pubblicato o
comunque della musica rock e non dopo
averla sognata in 20 minuti così di
getto sto parlando di Yesterday
che poi non voglio dire che non esiste
musica di qualità al giorno d'oggi per
carità anche io 17 anni Anch'io ascolto
le canzoni che passano in radio tutto
ciò che vi sto dicendo adesso deve
soltanto farvi pensare
che andare controcorrente è qualcosa che
sempre esistito e sempre esisterà Spero
sia così perché senza ciò non rimarrebbe
nulla all'uomo non gli rimarrebbe la
musica non gli rimarrebbe il cinema
oltre all'arte c'è di più perché anche
amare un'arte e non dobbiamo mai
dimenticarcela essere prevedibili non è
mai stato nella natura dell'uomo e io
prego Rimanga così perché cosa sarebbe
la vita senza la sorpresa è
imprevedibile il modo in cui Cristoforo
Colombo ha scoperto l'America è
imprevedibile il modo in cui Isaac
Newton ha teorizzato la legge di gravità
e imprevedibile anche il modo in cui
Shakira si siano lasciati
E pensate quanto sarebbe imprevedibile
Se non avessi preparato nessun finale
per il mio discorso e me ne andassi
adesso
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Alessandro Conforti